[Music]
good afternoon everybody
thank you all so much for joining us
today and being here at this year's next
conference and making time on a Friday
afternoon to fill the house where we're
extremely excited to see all of you here
today to introduce myself my name is
Matt Moore
and I'm the product manager on the
Google cloud jobs API which was launched
in alpha this last November and today
I'm really excited to talk to you about
something that I'm extremely passionate
about which is job search but first of
all in this session what we're going to
do is we're going to take a
behind-the-scenes look at the jobs API
we're going to provide an update on what
we've been working on on the API since
our announcement in November and we're
extremely excited to be joined today by
the head of talent management at Johnson
& Johnson to hear about his experiences
deploying the API to the Johnson and
Johnson career site so first of all what
is the Google cloud jobs API well
obviously it's the first vertical
pre-trained machine learning model from
Google that's that's clear right but
what does this really mean to answer
that let's take a step back story time
here at Google we started with a simple
question how could we create a tenfold
increase in the number of people that we
hire we began by taking a deep look at
all of Google's hiring channels and we
found to our surprise that the Google
career site lets you see here was one of
the most scaleable channels and that it
was severely underutilized
so after analyzing user behaviors and
interactions on the career site we
realized if we were able to make even a
small change to the career site
conversion rate we'd be making a
material difference to the bottom of
wall
- excuse me to the bottom line to the
number of people that we hired every
year so we looked for opportunities
where we could optimize you know we ran
countless experiments and we focused
hard on improving the career site
visitor experience looking for every way
we could drive an increase to conversion
and ultimately generate high-quality
hires the resulting solutions which are
still in use on the Google career site
today feel free to take a look at we are
hiring became the first version of the
Google cloud jobs API so I'd like to
take this opportunity to introduce
Christian posts our chief data scientist
who's here to talk about the problems
we've seen along the way and what we've
done to solve them please join me in
welcoming Christian to the stage hi
everyone can you hear me so yes let's
take a second just to talk about one of
the main problem that the job API is
trying to tackle so as you know there's
no stone up for writing job posting so
very often what we're seeing is
companies which are struggling and using
some kind of internal language for
describing job titles that may not be
obvious to job seekers so you can see a
few of them up there they are real we
have seen them to the judge API they are
not the worst one and I'm sure that if
you are in industry you can come with
winner ones on the other hand job
seekers do not have a PhD in terminology
and so they cannot anticipate all the
possible ways that a title can be
expressed so even if you are a recovery
and asset protection specialist you may
never find this wreck and asset prod
level one jobs because how on earth you
know it's spelled this way so the Google
charge or dpi is like a translation
engines errors s don't like to call it
that helps match the employers interest
with a judge seekers interest so now if
you are trying to fill this reg an asset
brought level one position dpi is going
to help you surface a job to the job
seekers which are best suited for it
about the residence stone if you
remember this is a stone that was
rediscovered by the French in Egypt in
1799
it contains three translations of the
same decree at the bottom it is an
ancient Greek was known at the time the
top one it was ancient Egyptian
hieroglyphs that was unknown and thanks
to the stone 20 years later a French
scholar was able to translate or
decipher hieroglyphs so I like to think
about the job seeker queries like the
ancient Greek canon of it what's going
on you have the job posting titles who
have no idea this is the higher place
essentially the API is the Reza stone
but the best way to fill the problem is
to sit in action so let's look at the
search behavior on the previous version
of the Johnson and Johnson carry website
and we're going to take a very simple
query like searching for admin assistant
role in New York what could go wrong
well if you look at the results to be
surprising there always matches and
there are a couple of reasons for that
the first one is the realizations at
various on job titles are the
combinations of very generic term two or
three very general term independently
each term is very vague but when you put
them together they create a very
specific meaning and this makes any
keyword research very challenging okay
you saw that problem there are more
issues one is that an admin assistant is
a supporting role for senior positions
so it will tend to be mentioned in the
job descriptions of the more senior role
and now you have an increased risk are
returning the senior role in the search
results for the admin assistant query
just because you had a hit on the
secondary
all in the job descriptions for the
senior role and what happens here
essentially if you look here all of
these jobs are pretty senior and by
doing so you are missing the job the
intent of the job seeker so the EPA is
tackling this issue and many others and
we will see a bit more in future but how
did it work so at the core of the Google
cloud VPS are data models that encode
our knowledge about occupations skills
education locations companies
implemented and more what you're seeing
here is a visual representation of one
of our data models which is the title or
occupation data model so for once again
just imagine that you're at night and
look in the sky try to do that to night
that would log into the francisco
there's a fog so go back home and look
at the sky imagine that every star
you're looking at is a title related
titles are close stars in a sky and like
stars concentrating galaxies titles that
belong to the same job categories will
tend to concentrate in clusters so if
you look at our skies we have some
exciting galaxies here like the
accounting and finance or the business
operations or the artifice fashions and
design each galaxy is made of thousands
of titles and we understand around
250,000 titles yes but much more
interesting is if you look at the
structure within the galaxies there's
fine structures that encode the type of
similarities between those titles okay
so we are in the age of space travel
right so maybe we can go with some of
these stars you want to do that I don't
even know what I'm asking you because
anyway you don't have a choice door
closed so put your seat belt and enjoy
the ride so let's look at the video so
our journey is going to start by
visiting the business development
manager star so that what we want to see
with this video is a couple of things I
will tell you what you would have
visited so if you are in the business of
mcmanager star you're going to see in
the neighborhood space they are very
small nuances of that title oh thank you
finally we're taking off excellent
there we go we are in advertising and
marketing galaxy so the first thing you
can see here in the closeby space we are
capturing very small nuances like a
business development or can be a
business development director so we have
businesses between it manager and
director you have a business development
marketing manager we also captures a lot
of vertical BD manager role like a
government Business Development Manager
IT Development Manager or store I think
retail business develop manager so those
are small nuances would capture but a
business diplomat manager can be also
expressed in many different ways like
for example a brand development manager
so we just visited a nearby space we
went a bit further and you can see here
we exemplify a few more alternative of
how a business development manager is
being expressed it can be mentioned as a
director of brand strategy or a
strategic planner partner relationship
manager even a chief marketing officer
or an account marketing executive okay
so now we will switch and we're going to
go far far away galaxy which happens to
be the transportation and logistics
direction and we're going to visit the
star which is the truck driver store so
it takes a little while because really
we're going to go across the universe
there we go
as you can see again we have tons of
neon shoes around the truck driver so in
nearby space you capture things like a
delivery driver or a class A CDL driver
a 7.5 ton driver or things like court
order or tow truck coordinator but the
most important thing is to realize is
there are strong differences between
those roles for example a V weight and
light weight truck driving have very
different driving requirements in terms
of driver license so you never want to
return heavy weight driver roles to
light weight your driver queries
because there's a mismatch okay finally
we're going to go into the admin
assistant role that we saw a bit earlier
which happens to be in the initiative
and office galaxy which is a good one
same pattern here you can see that we
have all the possible nuances of for
example Alameda season can be a personal
assistant of the assistant secretary
administration coordinator and so on
we again capture a vertical administer
exactly the admin assistant or store
admin assistant we capture also
different seniority level access senior
administrator or admin assistant one two
or three ok so we're done well space up
you're not too dizzy but as you can see
it was a fast travel some hook up at the
very beginning but we did this travel
and we never spend quality time at one
of these stars so what we're going to do
now is take a break take a vacation and
revisit one of these stars the exciting
Business Development Manager one and try
to explore in more depth so what it is
earlier is we understand a lot about
this title the first thing is we
understand all the possible synonyms
again we Express especially also slang
ones so if you are in a beast debt world
you may spell something like busy in one
single world where we capture a business
development in that case you can use
abbreviations there - those are captured
you just saw earlier we understand a lot
of all the related rules we also have
relationships and strengths of
relationships between those roles
those are captured earlier you saw that
this world belongs to the advertising
and marketing galaxy but actually it
belongs to more galaxies than that it
also belongs to the sales galaxy and the
management Alexei you want to capture
all of these facets of the diamond that
a business atomic matter role is and all
of these reasons if we have them with
confidence score so you know the
strength of the relationship finally we
also understand what are the skills
related to that role and since we are
talking about the skills what we do a
small deep dive into our skills ontology
and we're going to use the Business
Development Manager role to exemplify
what we're trying to build so what you
are seeing here is a simplified snippet
of our skill to the model we will Italy
to the business
good manager case so the first thing is
if you are a business development
manager you must have business
development skills like kind of a dull
moment right but actually the critical
one because at this point in time we can
start reasoning about what it means
business development skills
it's a collections of different skills
such as brand building finding business
opportunities relationship buildings
sale skills strategic management skills
but if you have sales skills you better
have good communications and
interpersonal skills so what you're
seeing here you'll see we have a graph
of skills with different type of
relationships which is encoded by this
different type of arrows here so some
skills are part of larger skills some
skills are collections of skills and
skills are prerequisites of skills some
skills are related to other skills like
for example the business development
skills is related to strategic
partnership development and more
importantly also we understand the
relationship between occupations skills
and education so we need earlier the hub
from business development manager to the
business development skills business
development belongs to the larger
business skill which is commonly
associated with an MBA degree which is
included here ok so we talked about the
mismatch between job seekers and
employers we talked about us this
beautiful data models well how do we
bridge the two and this is where machine
learning comes into play
so essentially machine learning helps us
extract content on both sides from the
employer and the job seeker and map the
content to the data model with great
accuracy once we have done the mapping
essentially we can leverage Google
search technology for retrieving and
ranking search results so here on the
left you see the employer so whenever a
job posting is inserted in the private
tenant on a Google cloud platform with
passenger posting and we structure it so
we are going to use our natural language
processing and machine learning for
essentially building
structure for example first thing we do
is we automatically segment the Job
Description into its main constituents
which are responsibilities company
descriptions requirements and other
subsections we also extract to dozens of
what we call nuggets like for example
all the leaves turn the leaves stick
leaves vacation we extract all the
benefits if they are present on a job
posting we extract things like shifts X
ability life insurance 401k tuition
reimbursement so we extract this data
and we normalize them and resurface them
we also extract animalizer skills from
the requirement section also something
you saw earlier with the magically
categorised job posting into one of
these broad categories or galaxies a bit
earlier so we create a very large set of
metadata that were going to leverage in
the search on the right side we see the
job seeker so when the judge API gets
the job seeker query we do the same work
we try to on each side there is a title
and prominent type the company skills
education statement
pretty much anything that moves which
word you detect it and normalize it so
that we can now match to the rich
metadata of the job posting we just
talked about so maybe we can take a
minute to go visit one of these data
processing that we have built and one
example maybe we can use is our title
sanitizer so as you know job posting
titles are very very noisy I think
pretty much I would just give you an
example I think on the millions and
millions of posting that we have
analyzed we found out actually
the number of unique strings that you
can extract in terms of stat alone job
postings it's pretty much just reuse
your set by 75% so essentially if you
have ten millions of postings you end up
with 2.5 millions job titles which are
eunuch strings it's very nice why
because there are ads and so often you
find
content that does not describe the
occupation you find things like location
company name employment type but you
find things also like advertising jargon
needed wanted right opening and
sometimes you find extremely useful
information lacking administrative
Jorgen like a reference ID on a job
posting so the first thing that the
judge BPI does is clean up the mess and
then we solid eyes the remaining
contacts so if you have acronyms
abbreviations we also do contextual
disambiguation and finally also we
extract the skills and specialties from
the the job postings and happen that to
the title at this point in time we built
a high dimensional vector
representations of those titles the
dimension of the vectors essentially are
terms and expressions that we have
gathered from the titles and the skills
extracted from millions of job postings
across hundreds of thousands of current
website so now we can use machine
learning at this point in time we built
a classifier it's an awesome classifier
that is a collection of natural language
based processing classifiers and neural
nets and the classifier will attempt at
mapping the the statement that you are
fitting it so this title string into
zero one or more occupations in our
title data model why hero you asked I'm
glad you asked
well a princess of darkness it's a title
we have seen and I use that all the time
so not CHR oh no princess of darkness so
unless you have some extra information
that will extract it from a job posting
like skills we must be able to say I
have no clue what to do with that on the
other hand very often especially on the
query side especially also with the blue
colors and those skills you don't find
very specific title styles and to be
pretty vague so you must be able like a
riddle sales or team members or I want
to work in the warehouse
you must be able to map the query or the
titles to not a single node into the
ontology but to a multitude of them and
we do that with confidence core which
means that whenever we do the mapping we
have a sense that the mapping was done
without ambiguity or maybe with some
ambiguity and we take a take care of
that also in a search results okay so
that concludes our little deep dive into
the title analyzer we have similar
sanitizers for education for skills and
and others but I think at this point in
time you are much more excited to see
how the surface into the product so I'm
going to hand back to Matt to see our
customers are using the API today thank
you all right Thank You Christian so our
goal is to bring this next wave of
computing to the entire talent industry
fundamentally changing how employers are
able to attract connect with and retain
talent job search if you think about it
it's just the first step in this api's
journey I mean almost every business
starts their hiring processes with job
search and as we found once optimized
it's a very powerful tool and you're
hiring arsenal so by working with
existing independent software vendors
and job platforms we aspire to create
turnkey access to the API we want to
provide a better job search experience
for all employers and candidates because
let's face it hiring the right people is
one of the most important things your
company needs to do to date we've
announced two core use cases both of
which are running in a closed alpha
program in North America the first one
powering job boards
for the job board case we are pleased to
share that Careerbuilder is nearing a
production release and ongoing testing
and improvements continue to date with
dice comm our second an extremely
important use case is powering talent
networks and company career sites we're
also pleased to announce for
Careerbuilder that they've brought over
20 companies online with the API in
their talent network including CIO X
health gamestop and Lucas group helping
thousands of job seekers find their next
job going forward
additionally the cloud jobs API
continues to power job search on the
Google and FedEx career sites and later
this month gibe will be onboarding
health self the largest owner and
operator of inpatient rehab hospitals in
United States and eatin a multinational
power management company specifically
for Google and our online hiring efforts
our career site handles several million
queries each month and we've seen a 28
percent increase in candidate success
rate from apply to hire since our
journey with the api began and last but
definitely not least we're pleased to be
joined here today by one of our newly
on-boarded customers Johnson & Johnson
so please join me in welcoming up to the
stage Shore daring global vice president
of talent acquisition at Johnson &
Johnson and Joe sm Feld CEO and founder
of jive welcome up
GEMA
there we go all right thanks for joining
us here today guys and it's great to
have both of you here to talk about the
child's API so short I I was wondering
to kind of start us off could you talk a
little bit about you know Johnson &
Johnson's hiring processes and some of
the challenges you face absolutely Matt
a pleasure to be here today at Johnson &
Johnson we fill about twenty five
thousand positions a year and as a
company we have a goal in the next
decade to find a cure for cancer
I'm sorry heavily investing in our
oncology and haematology businesses
currently we have approximately 350
rules open today Indian ecology and
ethology space primarily in the research
and development in various commercial
rules given the fact that these rules
are so niche and so hard to hard to fill
we're having a real issue filling these
positions simply because we're tapping
into a very small talent pool and our
current approach is really not getting
as to the hiring goals that we need fast
enough so we're always looking for
innovations related to job search and
hiring practices Wow you know um you
know when you first started chatting
with Joe about the machine learning and
the API you know what what was it that
caught your attention as a possible way
you could use this to solve some of
those challenges yeah we've been
interested in machine learning for a few
years now really because we believe that
it can enable us to much better identify
and hire talent faster and one of the
things that we need to do a much better
job of is to proactively identify and
match people with the skills and
interest in the oncology space to our
various open positions and we feel that
the jobs API it can actually make a real
difference here and I understand it may
have had a previous look but at that you
and Joe have brought some examples to
share with us today we have so we
prepare three different examples for the
audience today the first one it's a
search query around oncological research
and in the location
the United States
and what you see on the left side of
this slide is our previous keyword
search or keyword based search
technology and on the right side you see
an example using using Google search and
as you can imagine on the left side a
job seeker would actually be quite
discouraged having searched for
oncological research and not seeing any
on quality specific positions in the top
search results that that the search
yielded on the right-hand side where you
see our Google search results is that
Google search is actually using the
understanding of language to return much
more much more relevant jobs even when
it doesn't use the exact M keyword in
these jobs the other thing that you see
in this result is that the Google search
yields fewer and much more quality and
relevant search results over over the
before picture which really saves
jobseekers quite a bit of time the
second example is around a search query
around micro microbiologists and what
you see here is that although the first
the first example the first two examples
are pretty similar
further down in the list you start again
to see Google search returning much more
relevant and job-job queries or job
search results for and for jobseekers
and last but not least the third example
here is around internships in New York
City and we get an enormous amount of
job of search queries around internships
at J&J and I actually thought this was a
particularly interesting example because
the before picture you see four four
results in in in desserts three of which
aren't really relevant and the after
picture there are 11 relevant internship
results in the New York and New York
City area
much more relevant for job seekers again
using using Google search yeah so I mean
first of all thank you so much for being
here and sharing these examples with us
you know we're we're really excited to
continue to work with you as you move
forward hiring so you know Joe just
having heard from short could you maybe
tell us a little bit about the API
onboarding process with Johnson &
Johnson J&J was the second company to be
on board on the API and drive powers
career sites so when we're going to
production with jobs for a global
company like J&J one of our concerns are
how do you deal with that with a closed
alpha program you know you're putting
jobs in production you're handling this
big responsibility of hiring and with
collaboration with Google we were able
to successfully put in place some
measures to make sure that even though
as an alpha program we had a successful
launch one of the things that we found
very helpful was actually having a
customer success function installed in
this early adoption program
so as we launched these jobs and J&J
being the second one we're able to do it
in about three times faster so we got
J&J live from the time we got the thumbs
up in about a week and going forward we
now have a turnkey interface that any
existing job client can be live on this
API in under a day and can begin testing
so it really gives us a space to do that
but beyond that quick turnaround time
we're able to actually interface and
make sure that the job families the job
descriptions the job application process
we're all maintained and we can maximize
that value of that machine learning
process and not have to worry about
production issues with such a young API
so it went very smoothly and we're two
for two so far we hope the trend
continues absolutely you know as you
brought you know Johnson & Johnson and
more companies going forward online have
I been anything that's you know
surprised you about hiring or you know
the API in general yeah I think there
were two things really with J&J that
were surprising the first one was how
important location searches we were very
focused on understanding this story and
the benefits behind machine learning
talking about the translation and
looking at the relevance of search
results like short shared about
oncological research and microbiology
but we started really analyzing the
query data we notice how often job
seekers search for location they search
for location in the keyword field they
search for location location field and
the lift that we saw
you know jive we pride ourselves on
having good products all around but our
location search didn't match Google's at
all it was more based on radius and
being from Manhattan and working there
you know when you do a radius search for
job in Manhattan you end up with
suggestions in Hoboken and Jersey City
and Queens and no offense of those
places but people typically don't want
to work there when they're searching for
a job in Manhattan so we yeah so we saw
some great lifts with location alone and
also the ability of the API to parse out
the result in the keyword field so job
seekers don't like following directions
and when you looked at the data we saw
the keyword field were just polluted
with all this information and the
machine learning API was able to parse
that out return intelligent results back
and improve conversion when we had that
so that was the first surprise there and
then the second which was really funny
was this emotional connection that
people had understanding that machine
learning was powering the search at
first it was trying to debunk it oh I'm
going to find this I'm going to find the
query that's going to show this thing
doesn't work and then they're pounding
the API they're looking for result and
then what they find is how well it works
may start to understand that it's not
about keyword search but it really goes
back to Christians example about
translation and a good example was a
query that someone put in for sequel so
they were looking for jobs related to
that and the first result that came back
and this wasn't for J&J was for another
client on the API was an HR admin
position no I got it we found we found
it that this didn't work and as they
clicked into a job it wasn't in a
database category was an IT category but
at the bottom of the Job Description it
mentioned how important it was about
pulling reports from sequel so this was
a great example of how that keyword
actually surfaced the skills required
for that job and that person switched at
that point from being trying to debunk
it to then try and find more examples of
how this machine learning really worked
so those are two great surprises as we
implemented this in my life also you
know we we always loved creating more
believers in it so uh thanks for sharing
you know in the last few minutes we have
here on the stage is there anything else
you might want to share with folks in
the audience who would be interested in
improving their hiring process and
talent search sure I think one thing
that's really important to think about
is job seekers as consumers when they're
on a company's career site that is when
they're the most engaged and it really
has to be like any other transaction or
an e-commerce site
any other consumer-facing site and when
you think about machine learning it's
important to think about it in that
consumer frame so we want to find the
positions that are most strategic to
fill and understand how that translation
of what those job titles and job
descriptions are are really relevant to
those job seekers so I'd say take a step
back don't think about quantity and just
filling your pipeline but what's
meaningful to your company and how does
that translation through machine
learning really help improve your
conversion and we start thinking about
in that context you get a lot more
support and understanding inside the
organization but how to consumer eyes
that experience for job seekers and
really improve candidate experience
awesome well again thank you very much
for both joining us today and for being
an excellent partner through this alpha
program and hopefully beyond insured
thank you so much for taking the time to
share your vision both for Johnson &
Johnson and the API today it's been
great working with both of you and we
hope to continue it going for it thank
you very much thank you great all right
so I'm sure you're all excited to see
what's next for the API and today we're
pleased to announce several updates to
the Alpha and share with you some of our
future plans for the API we've been hard
at work these past few months evolving
the jobs API to address additional
customer needs and prepare the API for
broader adoption which I'm sure you're
all interested in so first of all we've
added featured jobs which enables a
hiring company to promote jobs that it
has a business critical need to fill as
soon as possible
and be seen by as many job seekers as
they can get it in front of secondly
we've added histogram which is the
ability to include and render dynamic
search counts alongside your filters
which is going to greatly improve the
understandability
of your search results in experience
next
give added support for bulk operations
bulk operations allows you to send
multiple creates updates or deletes in
the same call which is a much requested
an extremely useful feature when you're
managing a lot of job data like many of
our customers do and finally we've added
significant relevant threshold
improvements further ensuring our
objective - excuse me - return great
matches for all job seeker queries and
in showcase the search quality of the
API but now let's take a look at what's
coming next so in the first quarter of
this year we'll be rolling out some
important changes and enhancements to
the API to start we're going to be
making improvements to how we handle
locations in your job data improving our
support for both jobs without locations
which happens and jobs with many
locations this quarter we're also going
to be introducing integrations for
behavioral data improvements to our
existing data models which will further
improve your search results looking
forward this half of the year we're
aiming to graduate our API into beta
expanding and making the API prepared
for greater public availability you know
with the beta launch we're also aiming
to release a couple of cool new features
such as commute search which we're going
to talk about more in a moment and job
to job recommendations improving on our
models which will build smarter
associations between jobs in the system
and finally as we look to the future
we've got an ambitious set of goals for
the API to bring and expand the API to
customers worldwide translating and
localizing in new countries and
languages and while we started with job
search our goal is to take this machine
learning powered API to the next level
and enable job to person recommendations
helping generate smart job
recommendations based on resumes and
profiles so your job seekers never even
have to search you know because search
it's not always the right tool for the
job it's limited to being initiated by
the job seeker and this next step will
move the API forwards leveraging machine
learning to intelligently match job
seekers with your company's open
opportunities but let's take a moment
and dive into one of the features that
I'm extremely excited today to reveal
for the first time which is the ability
to search jobs by how long it takes to
commute to work so as a little
background it's been shown that an
employee's commute has one of the
strongest ties to job satisfaction and
when you're trying to attract and retain
the best talent employees need to be
satisfied with all aspects of their job
including how long it takes to get to
work now there are many job seekers that
depend on the availability of timely
public transportation to get to work a
job that's 20 miles away you know may
take over two hours to get to by bus
which is time that can be spent at home
with your family an employee that has to
spend two hours commuting every day is
probably going to be an attrition risk
and even for drivers job search until
now has been entirely straight line
distance based and that's useful if you
can afford to fly to work every day most
job seekers don't have that luxury or a
straight line route to work and when
you're commuting during normal business
hours there's something that slows you
down even further which is traffic I'm
sure you're all familiar with it you
know with commute time search we're
aiming to help job seekers make informed
decisions around where their next job is
located and be happier more effective
employees let's take a look at the demo
and pray the internet works
all right so we've uh we've loaded up
this quick demo running on the API to
demonstrate how you might use the API to
allow job seekers to search by commute
time on the right you'll see the browser
developer console which is showing the
real-time API output and we've loaded
this instance up with some test data for
software engineering positions where you
can specify a street address which is
Sunnyvale in this case a method of
transportation which is either public
transit walking or driving and we'll
pick driving here and the amount of time
you're willing to commute which will
leave it 30 minutes in this case when we
search we can see the API returns jobs
that have street addresses specifically
reachable within 30 minutes as indicated
by the blue area on the map and as you
can see for this job in particular we
were able to identify the company street
address and determine that this job is
28 minutes away in traffic to take a
look at another quick example let's
search from an address in the city of
San Francisco say the downtown area
where we all are right now and because
I'm commuting from the city I'm more
interested in public transit options and
I live in San Francisco I have a high
tolerance for commute say 60 minutes or
so when I search I can see the extremely
non polygonal set of locations where we
return jobs which are influenced by
local public transferred options BART
which takes you up to Walnut Creek and
Cal train which takes you down into the
peninsula and we can get an accurate in
specific understanding of where I can
reach in an hour from the city which is
very important if I don't have a car for
example you know this is a brand new way
of representing location based job
search one that's more reflective of the
actual experience of traveling where did
I go traveling between home and work so
we're sorry just jumping back to the
slides here
you know we're excited to share this
with you today and you know that's your
sneak peek at the future of the jobs API
which you can look forward to seeing
more about in the next couple of months
we hope you enjoyed this first look at
this brand new feature and we're excited
to be making this available to our
customers going forward in the near
future and we really can't wait to see
what awesome stuff they bring to the
table with it but thank you so you're
probably all wondering at this point how
to get started with the jobs API if you
manage a company's career site and we
already have a number of approved
reseller integrations in place at this
time we recommend you contact your
applicant tracking system or career site
provider to ask about leveraging the
jobs API and if they're not already a
reseller encourage them to sign up with
Google at the web site you see here
cloud.google.com
slash jobs - API for anyone here that
runs an applicant tracking system or is
a career site provider or a job board or
any other business interested in
leveraging the API please also visit
cloud dog or calm slash jobs - API to
register your interest in the service
and we'll get back to you shortly
our API is still in alpha and once we've
granted you access getting started with
the API is as simple as setting up a new
project in the cloud developer console
and registering your account with our
service
[Music]
you